So let's look at an example of deductive reasoning. So Premise A, is all mass
creates gravity. And Premise B, is all objects have mass. Therefore, all
objects create gravity. Because if all mass has gravity and all objects have
mass, then they must create gravity. Notice that the logical conclusion has to
be true if the 2 premises are true. We know, however, that this type of
reasoning can lead to correct conclusions only when the general premises to
which they are based are true. Let's look at another example. Premise A,is I
don't know math. Premise B is, I can't learn math. Therefore, I shouldn't even
bother trying to learn math". We see, here, that this reasoning leads to a
false conclusion, because premise A is false. And so is premise B. So, even
though the argument is. Easily structured in the same way. One leads to an
accurate conclusion, and one, this one, does not. Deductive reasoning is what
scientists use when we make predictions for our general goals. Now let's go to
Susan and talk about inductive reasoning.